- [Narrator] Four decades
after its creation,
Silicon Valley Bank was the
16th largest bank in the US.
It took just a day and a
half for it to fall apart.
- This is the second biggest bank failure
that's ever happened in the United States.
- [Narrator] Once seen as a
major tech banking player,
SVB's stunning collapse
spurred other bank closures,
rattled global markets
and threatened the livelihoods of startups
across the country.
So, what went wrong?
Silicon Valley Bank opened in 1983
to serve fledgling tech companies.
Eventually, nearly half of the country's
venture capital backed technology
and life sciences companies
would rely on SVB.
Roku, ROBLOX and many others
put millions into the bank,
helping SVB become one
of the nation's largest.
- Some of these clients
would definitely be considered risky.
These are companies that move quickly
and their money moves quickly.
When things sort of went off the rails,
they were quick to move
their money out of the bank.
- [Narrator] After the banking crisis
that triggered the Great Recession,
President Barack Obama
signed the Dodd Frank Act,
making banks like SVB
face stricter regulation.
- It is designed to make sure
that everybody follows
the same set of rules.
- [Narrator] But eight years later
during the Trump administration,
some of those regulations on
smaller banks were rolled back.
- By liberating small banks
from excessive bureaucracy
and that's what it was, bureaucracy,
we are unleashing the economic
potential of our people.
- Some of the rules were
rolled back for these banks
that had less than $250 billion in assets.
So you have the biggest banks
like Bank of America and Chase.
Those have very strict rules
but the ones that are a step
below have looser rules.
- [Narrator] Two years later,
SVB was flooded with cash
as businesses deposited
more during the pandemic.
Deposits tripled in two
years to $189 billion,
making 2021 SVBs most
profitable year ever.
- [Becker] Our core business
continues to fire on all cylinders.
- [Narrator] So SVB
Financial took that cash
and bought tens of billions of dollars
of longer term US treasuries
and government backed mortgage securities.
Products usually considered safe.
- People and companies just put
money in their bank accounts
and banks said, we have
to do something with this.
We have to earn some income on it.
So they bought bonds with it.
- [Narrator] SVB's securities portfolio
rose about a hundred billion
dollars in under a year.
- After SVB had stockpiled
that hundred billion
dollars plus in bonds,
all of a sudden interest rates rose.
- Committee anticipates that
ongoing increases in the target range
for the federal funds
rate will be appropriate.
- What happens when
interest rates rise is,
bond prices fall.
Banks, including SVB that were
holding onto a lot of bonds,
were sitting on a bunch of losses.
- [Narrator] Soon, SVB's investments
were worth $17 billion
less than their fair value.
- And so all of a sudden,
the gap between what SVB
had paid for those bonds
and what they were worth on paper
had jumped to more than $17 billion,
and that was the key risk
that would eventually
lead to SVB's undoing.
- [Narrator] Making matters worse,
as interest rates rose,
new deposits shrank,
falling nearly $30 billion
from March to December.
Talking about the end of 2022,
CEO Greg Becker told CNBC,
- We kind of felt that that bottoming out.
We've kind of felt that we were
kind of at that, that lower point.
- [Narrator] The vast majority
of the bank's deposits
were held in just 37,000 accounts
that held more than $250,000.
The amount insured by the FDIC.
Then in a regulatory filing on March 8th,
SVB announced it sold a
large chunk of securities
at a loss of about $1.8 billion
to help it cover that decline in deposits.
- The regulatory filing that Wednesday
sparked a lot of fear.
The stock fell a tremendous amount,
which is never a good sign.
- [Narrator] And investors
were already on edge.
Crypto focused bank Silvergate
had just announced it would wind down
and return all deposits.
So the bottom was about to fall out.
Startup CEOs began receiving urgent calls
from panicked venture capital investors.
- He was out of breath like
he had just run a marathon
and he said, take your money out of SVB.
Go into your account,
take your money out as soon as possible.
- [Narrator] What started
as a trickle of withdrawals
quickly turned into a tidal wave
as word spread across the valley.
More and more startups pulled their cash.
It was a run on the bank
and the beginning of the end for SVB.
The next day, the bank's stock
price went into free fall
as customers tried to withdraw
$42 billion in deposits.
SVB ran out of cash.
- All of a sudden, everyone's
saying, whoa, wait a minute.
This bank is risky.
The bank has enough
money to cover deposits
if they come out in sort of
a peaceful, orderly fashion.
When everyone's racing for
the exits at once, it doesn't.
- [Narrator] That day,
regulators seized the bank.
The FDIC said in a statement
that customers would have
full access to their insured
deposits in three days.
But the bank had more than
$151 billion worth of deposits
at the end of 2022 that weren't insured.
They were over the $250,000 limit.
Two days after SVB's collapse
a second bank with a
different set of problems,
Signature failed and was
seized by regulators.
The third largest failure in history.
- And now people are
starting to worry about
other banks as well.
It's very much kind of a a
whack-a-mole situation right now.
Federal officials, state officials,
everyone's in sort of
this unenviable position
of trying to shore up confidence
in the banking industry
so it doesn't turn into
an even bigger panic.
- [Narrator] On Sunday, March 12th,
regulators announced that
even uninsured deposits over
$250,000 from the two banks
would be covered.
on Monday, March 14th,
Signature told clients
that due to the US Treasury
Federal Reserve and FDIC,
all deposits were not at risk.
SVB's focus on Silicon Valley
made it uniquely vulnerable to a run.
- Its fortunes were really tied to
the fortunes of this one industry.
But what's more, this is an industry
that has flighty deposits.
You can't really rely on this
short-term funding necessarily
to support these long-term
investments and bonds.
- [Narrator] Now some,
like President Joe Biden
are blaming the Dodd Frank
Act rollback for the failures.
- I'm gonna ask Congress
and the banking regulators
to strengthen the rules for banks
to make it less likely
this kind of bank failure
would happen again.
- [Narrator] With investigations
into SVB underway,
the bank's clients will
see their money returned.
But shareholders are out of luck.
When asked about the possibility
of bailing out Silicon Valley Bank,
the Treasury Secretary said,
- We're not going to do that again.
But we are concerned about depositors
and are focused on trying
to meet their needs.
(quiet music)